[Музика]
привіт всім мене звати Наталія
Лешко, час для уроку англійської мови,
давайте почнемо, тому
ваше попереднє домашнє завдання було написати
про
будинок і спортивний день у вас вдома, тому
сьогодні ми продовжимо
розмову про це  але у нас буде
урок письма,
тож, будь ласка, візьміть свої нотатки, підготуйте олівець
чи
ручку для письма, давайте почнемо,
так що це наше завдання, подивіться, ваша
школа організувала спеціальний спортивний
захід
, який ви створили, тому нам
потрібно написати
електронний лист вашому англомовному другові з
описом події та ваших
почуттів. Слова, які вам потрібно використати,
становить від 80 до 100, це максимум,
тому давайте ще раз подивимося на завдання,
і у
нас є чотири запитання, перше,
що ми збираємося  написати подивіться
на завдання
так, це електронна пошта, це важливо,
це не текст, це не стаття,
це необхідно електронний список,
давайте, номер два, це буде
для кого ви пишете чи ви
пишете своєму t  один
до ваших батьків до ваших друзів
ні, це англомовний
друг людина, яка розмовляє англійською, давайте
продовжимо
номер три, мова піде про
те, про що йдеться так, з тексту ми
бачимо, що мова йде про спеціальну
спортивну подію
і  останнє запитання, між якими ви повинні написати,
і це слова, яке обмеження слів
від 80 до 100 знову
101 все добре  у нас є карта розуму,
я б хотів, щоб ви скопіювали це у свої
зошити, і у
нас є текст, тому я збираюся
читати текст,
поки я читаю текст, будь ласка,
запишіть інформацію,
заповніть карту розуму за
такими категоріями,
щоб  вам потрібно вказати назву
події місце дату
різні дії та почуття, що
є найважливішою частиною,
тому давайте почнемо знову я пишу, ви робите
нотатки,
тому привіт, Тоні, як справи,
я щойно повернувся з  казкова
шкільна подія, яку
ми називаємо маленькою олімпіадою, і вона
відбувається
кожного червня на стадіоні біля нашої
школи. День розпочинався з того, що всі учні
входили на
стадіон з олімпійським прапором,
потім гра розпочалася, були бігові
перегони,
стрибки у висоту та стрибки в довжину  та інших
олімпійських видів спорту
для кожної події було троє переможців,
які отримали золоті
срібні або бронзові медалі я взяв участь
у дискусі та зайняв друге місце я відчував себе
дуже гордим
після того, як для всіх була їжа та безалкогольні напої,
мені було сумно, коли все закінчилося
, а ти  тримайте щось подібне у вашій
школі, прямо назад,
Брайан, тому я даю вам 30 секунд, щоб
упорядкувати свої ідеї, а потім
ми перевіримо разом
із дошкою
[Музика]
[Музика],
тож давайте поговоримо разом, давайте почнемо
з назви події
відповідно до  до тексту як називається
правильно маленька олімпіада давайте запишемо
молодець давайте перейдемо до наступного
це місце чи
можна знайти цю інформацію в
тексті будь ласка
так на стадіоні  біля нашої школи
давайте продовжимо, а що щодо дати,
чи є у нас ця інформація в тексті,
тож кожного червня правильно
давайте перейдемо далі давайте поговоримо про
діяльність,
щоб були бігові перегони
стрибки у висоту стрибки в довжину та інші олімпійські
види спорту,
тож давайте запишемо
це стрибки в довжину  стрибки
та інші олімпійські
види спорту
добре, давайте поговоримо про почуття,
як Браян почував себе добре,
так що подія була чудовою, добре,
він був дуже гордий,
чому саме він відчував гордість, ви можете знайти цю
інформацію в тексті
так, тому що він був другим, і він
добре впорався з моделлю  він також відчував себе дуже
розчарованим або дуже сумним, тому що
подія закінчилася
правильно, тому я можу написати почуття гордості
та сумні, коли подія закінчилася,
написання карти розуму, коли у вас є
урок письма
, дуже важливо, щоб у вас були
ідеї для написання  електронна пошта, давайте перейдемо далі
і поговоримо про різні почуття,
тому це буде завдання для вас
, подивіться на речення, у нас є
п’ять речень,
і у нас є п’ять слів, готових до  e
заповнено,
тож давайте обговоримо слова гордий, що
це означає гордий,
я був гордий отримати модель
добре, що щодо схвильований я схвильований вау, у
нас буде фантастична подія
так, враджані добре, давайте рухатися далі
розчарований або сумний сумний
розчарований суні  Рошані
так Брайан був сумний, що захід закінчився,
давайте рухатися далі виснаженими, тому після дуже
виснажливого дня у вас було багато дій,
ви багато робили, а потім ви відчуваєте себе
виснаженим, у вас немає сил, готових
до подорожі wisner добре і останнє слово  відчув
полегшення полегшений це щось на кшталт
розслаблений,
так що roslabani добре, я даю вам
20 секунд, заповніть речення
, будь ласка, у реченні номер чотири
і п'ять є два слова,
а потім ми збираємося разом обговорити
20 секунд
[музика]
[музика],
так що готово  щоб перевірити,
давайте подивимося на номер один я відчував себе
виснаженим,
я просто хотів спати, тому речення
сну допомогло нам зрозуміти, що
людина не виснажена.
dushfd номер два
я був розчарований тим, що подія була
Я хотів більше часу там, тому я відчував себе сумним
і розчарованим ні, не зупиняйся, будь ласка, ми
хочемо продовжити
Росс Серроне номер три
я відчув полегшення, що у команди не було
серйозних травм,
тому полегшення це щось на зразок розслабленого
удару спакіні,
немає проблем з командою  подивіться
на речення
у команди не було серйозних травм, тому, коли
щось відбувається,
наприклад, змагання, ви можете потрапити
в біду, і ви можете отримати травму,
командир mala jordan,
тому я знову переживаю спокійно, не хвилюйтеся, немає
проблем
номер чотири, давайте подивимось  я був таким
гордим
або таким схвильованим, коли я був першим
у стрибках у довжину, тому це залежить від вас,
що ви відчуваєте, що ви прийшли першим,
ви переможець,
тому ви можете пишатися або ви також можете бути
схвильованими,
ці поклони можливі, і давайте мати
подивитись на номер п'ять, це те саме,
я відчував гордість або схвиль, що
я стрибнув у висоту, хоча я не виграв,
мабуть, для мене, якщо ви запитаєте мене особисто,
я вибрав би для номеру чотири схвильований
і номер п'ятий, навіть t  хоча
я не виграв пристрої,
так, тому я відчував, що я дуже
пишаюся мною, це логічна комбінація,
але ви можете вибрати свій власний,
добре, давайте рухатися далі, тому
для вас буде ще одне завдання
і підготуйте ваші блокноти, тому подбайте про
подивіться на Грама-павука ще раз, у
нас є спеціальна спортивна подія, це
однойменна
назва, місце побачення, діяльність і відчуття,
і тепер це буде завдання на аудіювання,
яке
ви слухаєте та робите нотатки під
категоріями, готові, тож
давайте, ви слухайте та запишіть
привіт, Браян  дякую за ваш електронний лист,
було цікаво почути про цю
подію
в моїй школі ми проводимо спортивний захід
під назвою Huddersfield hoops
він проходить кожного вересня на
баскетбольних майданчиках в нашій школі
ця подія— це змагання з баскетболу три на три,
ви можете вибрати свій  власна команда, але це не можуть
бути всі хлопці та дівчата
цього року змагання були чудовими, я
був дуже схвильований грати в ігри, а
також моя команда виграла золоту медаль, тому я
відчував себе справді гордим
після того, як була їжа та доктор  чорнила
загалом це був чудовий день,
скоро Тоні
добре, ти готовий перевірити, я дам
тобі 10 секунд, щоб закінчити свої нотатки, а
потім ми перевіримо разом
три два одна зупинка, будь ласка,
тож давайте перевіримо, подивіться на
заголовки
ім'я Хаддерсфілд Хупс
грає на баскетбольних майданчиках у школі
дата кожного вересня, а не червня, зараз
почуття ентузіазму і гордість від
перемоги,
а також діяльність подивіться, учні
розміщують три на трьох
медалях у баскетбольних іграх за перемогу команди та їжу та
напої,
тому знову
згадується допомога з карти розуму  ми, щоб упорядкувати наші ідеї
зараз, давайте повернемося до тексту
подивіться
це текст, який ми щойно
прослухали,
і у нас знову є деякі прогалини, тому давайте
заповнимо слова
привіт Браян, дякую за ваш електронний лист,
щоб почути про подію  Тож яке
слово є найбільш підходящим для номера
один подивіться, ми маємо акорди власні та
горді, раді провести конкурс на медалі
цікаво або кожне, яке правильне
слово
браво, дякую, цікаво, тож давайте
прочитаємо сенте  Знову
було цікаво почути про цю
подію
давайте продовжимо в моїй школі
ми спортивний захід під назвою Хаддерсфілд надій,
то що це номер два
так правильно тримай тепер давайте прочитаємо
все речення
в моїй школі ми проводимо спортивний захід
під назвою хаддерсфілд обручі
давайте продовжимо  номер третій він проходить
вересень на баскетбольному полі в нашій
школі
давайте почнемо з першої частини номер
три він проходить
вересень правильно правильно
кожного вересня давайте читаємо ще раз це
відбувається
кожного вересня, а тепер давайте
закінчимо місцем,
де на баскетбольних
майданчиках молодці  давайте прочитаємо все
речення,
прочитаємо зі мною, воно відбувається кожного
вересня на баскетбольних майданчиках в
нашій школі,
давайте продовжимо цю подію,
це баскетбол три на три,
яке, на вашу думку, найбільш
підходяще слово тут
так, змагання в першу чергу я хотів
сказати "гра",
але тут у списку немає гри слів,
тому змагання є найбільш підходящим,
давайте прочитаємо ще раз,
ця подія - це 3-на-  три
баскетбольні змагання,
молодці, ви можете вибрати свою
команду, тому що ви можете вибрати,
ви можете вибрати свою команду так, ви можете
вибрати свою власну команду, так що давайте читаємо ще раз,
ви можете вибрати свою команду, молодець,
але це не можуть бути всі хлопчики і всі  дівчата,
тож команди треба змішати,
давайте продовжимо цього року змагання
були
чудові молодці, і номер сьом
подивіться,
я дуже хотів грати в гру,
тому я дуже голосував,
я був дуже схвильований, браво, я був дуже
схвильований,
граючи в гру, давайте рухатися
також моя команда виграла золоту
медаль «Что браво» моя команда виграла золоту медаль,
тому я відчував себе дуже гордим, молодець
давайте прочитаємо все речення, мені дуже
подобається,
також моя команда виграла золоту медаль, і я
відчував себе
дуже гордим, давайте закінчимо
після їжі  напої,
тому їжа та напої добре приготовані
після їжі та напоїв браво
загалом, це був чудовий день, скоро
Тоні, тому я б хотів, щоб ви прочитали
текст разом зі мною, давайте прочитаємо
весь текст,
це допоможе нам написати  ow  n електронна пошта
готова,
давайте йти за мною привіт, Браян, дякую за
ваш електронний лист,
було цікаво почути про цю
подію
в моїй школі ми проводимо спортивний захід
під назвою Huddersfield hoops
він проходить кожного вересня на
баскетбольних майданчиках в нашій школі
ця подія проходить 3-  3 змагання з баскетболу,
ви можете вибрати свою команду, але це не можуть
бути всі хлопчики
та всі дівчата, цього року змагання
були чудовими,
я був дуже схвильований тим, що грала в
гру,
також моя команда виграла золоту медаль,
тому я відчував себе справді гордим
після їжі  і напої загалом,
це був чудовий день, скоро Тоні
добре, тож тепер наша черга писати
електронний лист, тож давайте перш за все завершимо
карту розуму,
вона готова на моїй дошці, і у вас є
готова у ваших зошитах,
тож давайте писати разом, давайте  почніть
з назви заходу, у
нас була маленька олімпіада або день здоров'я та
спорту
в Києві, як на попередньому уроці, або
ви можете вибрати свою власну назву,
щоб маленька олімпіада була справді гарною,
можна запозичити цю ідею
давайте зробимо  це маленька олімпіада
добре зроблено, тепер давайте спочатку виберемо дату,
тому коли ви збираєтеся проводити цю подію,
мені дуже подобається ідея провести її
до кінця
навчального року, щоб ми могли провести її насправді
на початку червня,
тому що 1-го  червня - дуже
важливий день,
це день дитини, день дітей, тому
давайте 1 червня
добре зробимо, давайте рухаємося далі, ми маємо
місце,
де ми збираємося його мати в
попередньому прикладі, у
нас був стадіон біля школи, тому
я  я не впевнений, що в моїй школі є
баскетбольний майданчик,
тому я б вибрав стадіон біля
школи, ви згодні,
давайте зробимо це,
давайте продовжимо, а тепер давайте виберемо
заняття, які
нам дуже подобається футбол, я знаю, що ви робите, тож
давайте напишемо футбол,
що ще бігає  так що спринт
будь-що інше волейбол,
чому не
добре, ви збираєтеся включити їжу та
напої,
давайте виберемо це, чому б ми не любимо їжу та
добре зроблено.
щодо моделі, якщо ви
збираєтеся обговорити це,
будь ласка, додайте це слово, я відчував гордість,
що моя команда, наприклад, виграла модель
добре,
і, ймовірно, сумний, тому що подія
закінчилася
добре, давайте запишемо це,
тож давайте перевіримо ще раз один два три
чотири п'ять все  згадується ім'я
місце дата діяльності
та наповнення, тепер давайте напишемо електронного листа,
тому слідкуйте за мною, я збираюся ввести, а
ви пишете разом зі мною, використовуючи свій
блокнот,
тому
[Музика]
[  Музика]
[Музика],
тому наш електронний лист готовий, і ми збираємося
обговорити його
на наступному уроці. Я навмисно зробив деякі
помилки
, щоб ми могли їх знайти та
обговорити,
але перед цим для  на наступному уроці у
вас готове домашнє завдання,
тому напишіть свою електронну пошту, ви можете
слідувати моїм ідеям
або використовувати власну, щоб ваша школа
організувала спеціальний спортивний захід,
напишіть електронного листа своєму англомовному
другові з описом події та ваших
почуттів
та наступного уроку  ми збираємося дис  лаюсь,
щоб я чую, як дзвенить м'яч, це означає, що
нам потрібно припинити урок,
дуже дякую, що приєднався до мене,
побачимося наступного разу,
до побачення
[Музика]